Speaker 1: All right. I don't want to spend a ton
of time on this. Many of you emailed me about it.
This is really funny. Newsmax host Greg Kelly is
calling out Rudy Giuliani and saying, Dude, you're
claiming you got attacked. It seems like you're
exaggerating. So if you haven't followed this
story, let me back it up for you. Rudy Giuliani
was at. I guess it was like a shop, right?
And someone came up to Rudy and kind of patted
him on the back and I guess said something
negative to him. Okay. They patted him on
the back. And Rudy just turned around and
looked at them before the video was out. Rudy was
claiming that he was hit. It felt like a boulder,
that it knocked him multiple steps forward. He
thought it was I mean, that it was just like this
crazy, vicious physical attack. Then the video
came out and it becomes very clear that it was
not. Some guy patted Rudy on the back and said
something negative. Okay. Rudy has doubled down
and he keeps talking about this assault. And
this is so funny. Even cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs,
right wing Newsmax and its host Greg Kelly says,
I got to be honest, Rudy. It really doesn't
look that bad. So if you're watching, you'll
actually see the video of the I think they play
the video of the supposed assault. Check this.
Speaker 3: Out. See you do it. I didn't know it
was this good. I really did. And here's his grasp.
Speaker 1: By the way,
Rudy's audio plagued by background noise.
Speaker 3: Particularly in the issue prior to the.
More. Raising money and asking, Hey, Mr. Mayor,
is somebody mowing the lawn right outside your
window? I can barely hear you. We're at a big
rally. We're at a big rally in Staten Island,
right around the corner from
where I was attacked yesterday.
We have that, actually. You were at I guess we got
going. I want to show the people what happened.
And you tell me because let me see the video, if
you don't mind. This person with the hand on your
back. I got to be honest, it doesn't look that
bad, but I understand that looks can be deceiving.
You know, that that was that was the woman who was
rubbing my back, not the guy that you're watching.
So the woman that woman gave a statement to the
police. The guy hit me so hard that she herself
almost fell.
Speaker 1: Yeah,
it's very clear that didn't happen from the video.
Speaker 3: The reverberation of it. She's a see.
Speaker 1: The entire building echoed from when
Rudy was patted on the back. It reverberated.
They were worried it was going to break glass.
Speaker 3: There's a second grade detective
that. That's the lady who helped me. All
right, go ahead. That makes sense. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Guys, when Greg Kelly from Newsmax is
saying, you know, it really doesn't seem that bad,
you might have gone a little bit too far saying
that it reverberated throughout it reverberated
throughout the building. Can you imagine? So,
okay, so that's the Rudy thing. I don't really
want to talk about it too much more, but and
of course, if if some if someone doesn't want
to be touched, they shouldn't be touched. That's
absolutely the case. Okay. So I'm not defending,
but it was like a boulder. It knocked me
forward multiple steps. The guy patted Rudy
and Rudy turned to his left. That's all that
happened. Okay. So Greg Kelly is not buying it.